ومشاهدينا الاهتمام الروسي بملف الذخائر
الذكيه ياتي بعد ان ثبتت اهميتها الكبيره
في الحرب الاوكرانيه وتميل الكفه مشاهدينا
لصالح واشنطن في هذه النوعيه فالقنابل
الذكيه مشاهدينا التي قدمتها الولايات
المتحده لاوكرانيا تتفوق على نماذج
الذخائر الروسيه الموجهه بدقه بحسب خبراء
عسكريين نتحدث هنا مشاهدينا عن القنبلتين
الموجهتين الامريكيه جيدام والروسيه كاب
لنرى الاختلافات بينهما بين القنبلتين اذا
القنبله الامريكيه مشاهدينا يصل المداهه
الى نحو 72 كيلومترا مقارنه ب 14 كلم فقط
لقنبله كاب الروسيه العامل المشترك بين
القنبلتين هو ان كليهما يطلق من المقاتلات
الحربيه وهما موجهان بالليزر او بالاقمار
الصناعيه لكن القنبله جيدام الامريكيه
تتفوق في كونها مقاومه للتشويش على نطاق
واسع ويمكنها البقاء في مسارها الصحيح هنا
نتحدث عن نظام تحديد المواقع العالميه
يمكن تشويشهما لكن تعتمد قنابل جيدام على
نظام خاص يعمل على حساب قياسات السرعه
وموقع الهدف سلاح الجو الامريكي اعلن عن
تقديم القنابل الذكيه لاوكرانيا في ديسمبر
الماضي وتم استخدامها في المعارك بالفعل
ننتقل الان مشاهدينا اخيرا للقنبله
الروسيه كاب التي يحتوي او تحتوي على راس
حربي شديد الانفجار ويعتقد خبراء عسكريون
انها استخدمت لقصر مسرح في مدينه ماريوبل
الاوكرانيه في مارس من العام الماضي اضافه
الى استخدامها المتكرر ايضا في سوريا
[موسيقى]